(metal clicks)
- [Student] That one won't go.
- When we turn on the
hoverboard, what's gonna happen?
- [Student] It's gonna hit.
- Because our students participate in
meaningful projects, they are able to
think outside of the box.
They learn empathy and
realize that their dreams
may become a reality.
(clapping)
- Are you excited?
- Yeah!
- Part of the fabric of Eminence culture
is contributing to the larger society.
So we really try to encourage kids
to plug into what is a problem,
or an issue, or a gap
that needs to be filled,
and then how can you contribute to that?
So Wheels for Tate really
starts with this idea
that there is a kid in our
building who has a need,
and we feel like we can
take a shot at solving that.
- The fifth grade classroom
is at the other end
of our building.
Tate can't walk that really,
really, long distance,
so my Special Ed. Director
said, "Hey, wouldn't it
be cool if we could design
a hoverboard chair?"
We had about 27 kids sign up.
We'll talk about our parts and pieces,
and what we need to do
today to get it started.
- I said, "Well, how
are you gonna do that?
You know, a mobilized
wheelchair might be $15,000."
They started scouring the internet,
and they came back and said,
"We're gonna do it for $400."
- We had this picture and
a video it was based on.
- [Kelli] The kids came up with
the idea to sell advertisements
to go on back of the
hoverboard wheelchair.
So when you see any of those businesses,
make sure that you give
them a big thank you.
Tate, can you tell us how
does this make you Feel?
- Happy.
- After we had the funding
in place, the next step
was to actually design the vehicle.
We had to take Tate's
measurements to figure out
the dimensions for the frame.
We wanted to make sure
that we could make it safe.
Why did we chose to go with aluminum?
- It's light and very strong.
- [Kelli] This morning the students worked
on putting the vehicle together.
So they had to file the aluminum,
create the frame, attach all the pieces.
- It's really cool.
I've never done this before.
It's really helping me with math.
- [Student] Just measure
the actuals to make sure
it's centered and the bolts are on tight.
- [Bridget] We had to put
the wheels on the axle
and the chair on top of it.
We also had to think about the hoverboard
and it's placement.
- [Kelli] Guys, I see a
problem with that hoverboard.
I'm gonna wait and see if you guys can
problem solve and figure it out yourself.
- [Student] It's backwards.
- [Kelli] It's backwards.
- [Student] It's backwards?!
- And I tightened that thing really hard.
- [Kelli] We ran into a lot
of problems, but once they
figured it out on their own,
they have so much more
pride in their work.
- Once the plastic zip ties are secure,
the chair should be secure.
It's secure.
- So, moving forward, we need
to make sure it works, right?
So we're gonna test drive.
- [Kelli] Let's explain
to Tate, a refresher on
what he needs to do.
- [Student] He needs
to put equal weight on
both feet and lean forward.
- [Kelli] There you go.
Tate was so excited to hop on to
the hoverboard wheel chair.
He was able to sit down,
and he was able to get his feet aligned.
- [Group] Here we go!
(claps)
- [Student] Good job, Tate.
- [Student] So we're
trying to get handlebars
so Tate can steer.
- [Kelli] Those handlebars are going to be
so helpful for you.
- Yeah!
- [Kelli] You did good!
- [Student] Good job, Tate!
(claps)
- This project taught them
more than I ever could
in a 30 minute lecture.
It allows the hands on experience.
Also, building empathy
was a really key piece.
- Once you've made a
difference for another
human being, it's really
hard to stop that.
When I see the kid who I
built a mobility device for,
and his eyes light up,
and I've made his day
that gets in you and you
want to do more of that.
- It makes me feel good inside,
because I'm doing something good,
and no one gets left out.